assalamualaikum but now you know
recently our brother Andrew Tate was
arrested and left many of us wondering
what's going on
[Music]
The Matrix has attacked me the Matrix
has attacked me
this is
[Music]
to help shed some light on the situation
we've decided to bring out a very close
associate of Andrew Taylor 15 years a
close friend and brother Tam Khan
assalamualaikum brother
how are you doing good alhamdulillah Tam
Khan how you been how's everything going
alhamdulillah brother alive in kikins
alhamdulillah
so tell us what what happened where were
you when what were you thinking what was
your immediate reaction when you heard
the news
obviously my immediate reaction was a
bit of a shock as well as a
angry upset because uh another brother
well I was taken back but
I was also disappointed I was a bit
frustrated why did you even go back to
Romania not because you're guilty but
we know you're so despising the West
they don't like your ideas
uh they don't like what you're promoting
it's against their agenda since you
become Muslim that's added more fuel to
the fire so I mean of course he's got a
home there so he went back
work do some things check on his house
whatever you know the usual
and we were talking he was supposed to
be in Dubai in the 30th actually he was
coming back we spoke a little bit before
regarding some projects and something in
the sport world
and everything was good he had a good uh
podcast with Piers Morgan that week
which was successful he started with
salam alaikum
he uh
he apologized for past remarks on Islam
which was amazing it's the first time
you'll ever see Andrew take probably
apologize on podcast where he corrected
himself regarding comments of Islam in
his previous time saying that was when I
was atheist and Muslim so the whole
world got to see his
promotional Islam in a positive ways
promotion of the Middle East GCC Dubai
and I set them to a friend I said you
know
they're not going to like this there's
one thing whatever he said but
from in Islam this that I never expected
this to be honest and uh It's upsetting
because it's such a frame job it's such
a
like a hit on the brother because I know
him personally and there's a lot of
things I know a lot of people see as
podcasts the image of sunglasses the
very aggressive uh delivery but he's a
very sincere brother he's a very good
guy
um very loving I mean I'm a father
husband and I've got two daughters and
if if I thought as a Muslim in any way
he was
sneaky using Islam for the false reasons
or a threat I would myself you know I'd
be the first to pull him up so uh it's
unfortunate and uh it's the same old
case from April which they had no
evidence off they acquitted
I feel in my opinion
I'm not I'm just saying my opinion is
it's being a push from the west or maybe
U.S because she's U.S citizen uh there's
no
evidence what I can see so far there's
nothing but obviously Romania has laws
hence why it's a 30-day of uh sentence
because they're probably trying to
collect evidence to
present a case of prosecution
um but again I understand on their
behalf why they did the arrest for 30
days because for example if someone was
telling the truth you have to go for due
diligence and as a court or as a
prosecutor you'd have to arrest the
person until you know better but
unfortunately in this Society we have
many people cry wolf for clout for money
to assassinate characters we saw it with
Michael Jackson in previous series years
or other people who get too powerful for
their own like you know popular so
that's my opinion on the whole situation
I mean It's upsetting because he's a
brother and he doesn't deserve this you
know
yeah we were just actually uh planning
we had something set for to bring him
back on you know we had him on the
program before he was supposed to
actually come on on the on the program
back on the Dean's show this month and
then this just happened so I was very
sad tell me this um I want to ask you I
want to show you something and I want to
make this uh very lucidly clear as I've
spoken about this in the past you know
obviously human trafficking is something
evil it's beyond disgusting is demonic
and any person's involved such a crime
should be dealt with and in this Islamic
Society it'd be something non-existent
unlike what you have and you see
happening in our own backyards the
United States of America is one of the
largest consumers of human trafficking
you know there's not much talk about it
you know but it's something that's daily
happening here and I've spoken about
this in the past and the media is dead
silent on this another another note
before I show you this uh Tam is many
people are also asking uh about this
Epstein and all the elites that were on
that plane you know on the island who
are involved recently JP Morgan lawsuit
you know aiding in this and it's kind of
just went dead silent you know um so I
want to ask you this so that's kind of
just a a intro but now going off of what
you said do you think it has anything
and now I'm going to show you something
this is what people in Romania
to you know who live in Romania this is
uh many of them are saying this this
person lives in Romania okay he said uh
uh he has been connected with the
Romanian Elite who is the elite in
Romania the Orthodox Church the
politicians the police he made huge
donations to the Orthodox Church however
he recently converted to Islam Romania
is one of the most Christian countries
in the world and he may have pissed off
the wrong people his conversion to Islam
was a slap in the face to many
high-profile religious persons in
Romania this is just my own Insight okay
wow good point yeah good opinion that's
one that was said uh now another one
that just came in right now saying I
think you made a great Point here
because I'm just going back to the
interview we had the reason that he
lives in Romania is because it has
Traditional Values he was Christian at
the time and he says that it's like the
most Christian
place in Europe and they value
you know judeo-christian values and
everything like that so what you said
about the fact that he did convert to
Islam I don't know about 30 60 days ago
that I can under I can appreciate why
the Orthodox Church of Romania views
that as a slap in the face is that what
the guy basically said in the in the
Tweet yeah because he said that imagine
you said the the Christian they're
they're running the show over there yeah
when he gets out you know where he's
moving Dubai Sweden no I don't know
about Sweden but yeah he's moving to
Dubai what do you think what's your
reaction to this
hmm it's hot you know
I honestly
I mean we can't obviously kick it off
every everything there but it could be
look look yeah for sure look he was
hated as it was but coming to Islam
maybe that kind of support from that
kind of
demographic may have changed but a true
Orthodox Christian would still support
him because
the Old Testament
is of its course we believe the quran's
the truth and it's the final Revelation
that everything was tampered but they're
not as
distant as you think compared to New
Testament they kind of believe in the
same things same values I see what
you're saying I understand I see what
you're saying I don't think
I don't think this I think
these big tech companies I honestly
believe
the agenda against other things like
lgbtq and his stance on these kind of
things um I think the Orthodox
Christians are also supporters of this
so I don't think uh
they would sorry about that they would
uh go against that but you don't know
it's hard to say I don't know how
Romania's uh countries ruled I don't
know who has the biggest uh kind of
influence and whether it is that but it
didn't help obviously becoming a Muslim
didn't help and he's very outspoken he
promotes Islam he says
he doesn't discussion too bad but he
kind of says he's lost respect for it
how they accept everything and Islam is
uh makes him feel at peace I mean I'm
sure you saw social media content of us
in the most matches on Friday he he's
doing some also him reading throughout
the throughout the cave
reading the Clippers in English so it's
not like he's doing it for people to
always do it for fame no council mosque
he comes here we pray he uh other things
I can't say but I mean
your brother's a Muslim now of course
we're not saying he's a Darwin he's a
scholar that takes time from one extreme
to the other but he's a Muslim so I want
to put these allegations to doubt of
brothers and sisters who are mocking and
saying he does deserves what he did I
mean as a Muslim in general that's a
sinful thing to say we should support
our brother there's no uh evidence he's
been accused of like we had many
brothers subhana in the 2000s getting
arrested in Guantanamo Bay for no reason
for no reason you know just for family
and Muslim yet we defend what's the
difference between this just because of
the term they've used of course I don't
agree and I'll put my hands up to what
his past was in these webcams I hate
this whole thing I'm not for casinos
alcohol I think it's a rhyme and I say
clearly that's his past whatever it is
is disgusting but I truly do not believe
these allegations I do not like I said I
made a video a few days ago I said
unless I saw clear-cut proof of video
evidence or pure evidence of this I will
never believe it because I know how much
the media portrayed things brother today
I saw in the present UK tabloids as some
of the Daily Mail
a lady speaking saying how she was being
lured by him on social media to come to
Romania she's so happy she didn't it
could have been very dangerous for her
then the same uh lady I she came over to
us at a boxing fight a month ago with
Floyd Mayweather in Dubai she was a
wrinkle she approached him he was
sitting there looking over she walked
over willingly to him smiling I mean if
you're a fear of someone you approached
them in the first place if I fear
someone I'm not going to go to him say
hello so first of all already that's a
flaw and I'm sitting on my phone the
video's gone viral and I'm just head
down and I can listen
he's been very like
stiff thing look I'm watching the fight
and uh you can hear her saying what
you're doing tonight let's just talk in
general nothing wrong with her behalf
she's just talking in general being nice
uh asking him what his plans are and
then he goes look I'm watching the box
and he does this like this and she gets
a bit shy walks off today she's in all
the tabloids saying how
he's this and that so I'm thinking okay
and these are the people in this
feminist saying oh good on you you
fought him off but I'm all for like I
don't like if it's a rapist a human
trafficker that is sinful like you said
it's disgusting and there's real victims
out there and they deserve all the
sympathy and protection because that's
an evil heinous crime and I'm looking
for the Punisher of that evil but if
this is the case
um if this is the case and
this person's supposed to be a victim
yet comes and approaches him and uh
there's videos of this and he's saying I
mean come on and these tabloids are
selling newspapers today you see you see
look at her story you're so lucky you
got away so that's what you're dealing
with and I think people with any kind of
like logic or
open heart and mind we'll look into it
deeply like I said
why would you go back to Romania if you
had any incline you're guilty or that
investigation's still playing you know
about this Kim it was a dead
investigation you know like you would
not go whether you're of course you're
not you think you're not going to be
safe I'm gonna stay in the Middle East
it's all there to ruin
his kind of tempo the same way many
other influential people in history have
been I'm not saying he's an alchemist
I'm not saying this I'm just saying when
you get to a certain level where you're
kind of your Fame just hits the
Ruth you'll follow especially for that
younger generation it's dangerous to
them and um
I feel bad because I know the brother
genuinely away from things personally
um he's a very loving good guy he's got
a good heart like yourself he was going
to be in your podcast and other brothers
three or four Muslim Islamic Channel
podcasts were booked for this Channel
and we were going to go to a few tours
and many things in a
small things like uh
I cannot say but he was like uh you know
when I people are saying about my
tattoos what do you think should I cover
like he was asking these questions
he even says like you know many things I
did in my past I'm not happy with it
doesn't mean it's illegal he's just
saying I'm ashamed of it and there was
days when I was I think this was cool
but I hate it now so yeah again you know
as Muslims we believe it's a test anyway
at trial
I like the uh part where you mentioned I
actually spoke about this on Piers
Morgan where he came out he was an
atheist at the time and he said some
things uh and obviously he did a lot of
things at that time you're an atheist
you know what I mean you don't you're
not God conscious and at that time he
was talking about some things about
Islam he said look I came out he came
out on Piers Morgan and he apologized uh
for these things uh and you realize that
religion is actually the cure for most
of the problems in the world and
godlessness is the problem in the world
so that is something I will apologize
for to me I was wrong about because I
was atheistic and now as a Muslim I
understand that's absolutely not the
case you you regret saying that yeah
because you learn and you grow and you
evolve as I said uh at the time I
believed it because I didn't believe in
God at the time it was a very long time
ago it's actually kind of a testament to
you peers you managed to find the oldest
possible videos of me that have ever
existed he also was on his way I think
the best decision a human being can make
in their life is to come to Islam I'm
curious because you have recently
converted to Islam correct so these
questions I think are pertinent to your
conversion absolutely as to what you
actually believe as a practicing Muslim
now uh yeah I believe that Islam is
beautiful I believe it's the last True
Religion on Earth it's certainly the
last respected religion on Earth and I
felt differently inside since I've
converted and I think it has the
solutions to a lot of the problems we're
facing in the world today is to come to
Islam to the submission of the Creator
not the creation and obviously the more
you're in Islam the more that's going to
develop your character you're going to
become a better human being all around
he was uh I believe he also quit
drinking nothing's been hard I've got
alcohol that hasn't been difficult yeah
but I've always had insane willpower so
I can I can do anything I want to do I
just feel like it's a journey there's a
lot to learn it can be quite daunting
you know like even the even the language
even area it's like it's very hard to
learn so I'm just on a journey like
everyone else and I'm trying to you know
if you want a person you know pretty
soon gambling all of these things all
these vices that are out there one by
one because Islam calls you to
everything pristine everything beautiful
for everything that God Almighty loves
and it takes time like you were saying
give us it takes some time right so this
is very important there's a brother who
used an analogy he wanted to me he said
if I bring you a whole cake you don't
eat it I want to do you feel sick yeah
that's like Islam look he even said to
me because I'm involved in some casinos
I'm trying to step away from them Slowly
by slowly because I don't like it he
genuinely doesn't drink he's even I mean
you find me one podcast I want to
interview where Andrew has ever
apologized for a past remark about that
so that is something I will apologize
for admit I was wrong about because I
was atheistic and now as a Muslim I
understand that's absolutely not the
case yeah yeah that's deep that's that's
a test you know
that shows that shows a lot and no one's
mentioning that yeah
I caught that yeah this is uh yeah
innocent until proven guilty we forget
about this you know just I just want to
point just because someone's been
arrested and even come out their chart
doesn't automatically don't
automatically assume that they are
guilty you had a very famous case just
recently I don't know if our brother uh
Tam Khan we had a brother here uh Adnan
Saeed this happens a lot yeah right but
this is one famous case Adnan Saeed was
sentenced to life in prison plus 30 and
the judge deemed the ruling illegitimate
citing unreliable evidence and the other
Shady things that were happening you
know after around two decades the
brother was in jail two decades he was
finally released
he has been the subject of a popular
podcast for decades it's waking up a
free man this morning a judge overturned
Adnan syed's murder conviction citing
unreliable evidence now yesterday that
Baltimore judge ruled that the state
violated its legal obligation to share
new brand new evidence that could have
bolstered syed's defense well that
captured the attention of millions in
2014 through that podcast which focused
on the killing and raised doubts about
some of the evidence that prosecutors
had used since then Syed has had a slew
of supporters backing him no what do we
learn from cases like this that you know
people in law enforcement can lie
governments lie people often lie for
their own interests have you heard of
this case
there was a he was released recently
yeah just recently yes in two decades in
jail and the brother you know after
being charged convicted and he finally
got he finally got released so the point
of the matter there is that you have
people for their own interests like many
of these police officers at the time
they did things Shady things and finally
it was uncovered
so we can't be naive you know we have to
like you said yeah on this as well it's
not even about evidence it's about the
lawyers what they can present to the
court and the judge to prove like half
the time there's no evidence it's about
whose law is better than the other
literally yes this is the barcelon she
says to me is whoever can prove to a
jury or I'm not sure how Romania works
so it might not be no evidence it might
say you know what how you speak on your
podcast or how you've made terms like
he's made some delivery I don't like but
I understand that what kind of angle
he's using
women belong to men this that oh what
did you mean by that that means you oh
you can take anything out of context and
build a case that's how the West works
so unfortunately that's why Sharia law
is perfect that is why Sharia law is
perfect you don't get these situations
so again we go back to why the
Perfection of Islam the four Witnesses
not being around non-meter I'm not being
in these situations Haram vices so again
it comes down to the beauty of Islam
this won't have happened but
unfortunately our brothers in need and I
want to say one thing to all the Muslims
out there brothers and sisters there's
many sisters unfortunately
feminist and pushing this listen the
guys revert his or a clean slate if
Allah and the prophet is a guaranteed
that's clean who are we to question who
are you to question this and as any
Muslim whoever is a victim of something
you should support until like I said I
put my hand up if there was proof
clear-cut
without a doubt that he did it I'd be
the first to hands up and say look
that's wrong and Associate and say this
is a this is a crime but I don't believe
there isn't I know there isn't and I
know it's just going to be here to say
in my opinion so for a lot of pain girls
and girls who
money to make stories kiss and tells and
who's whose word you go by them
whose word you go by you know it comes
to this oh he said this how much you're
going to pay or can you set out of court
and sometimes then what happens and
stuff like he has to sell out of court
he's guilty either way you can't win so
unfortunately it's annoying but as
brothers like and Muslims we learn to
understand backfightings of sin
not trusting suspicion and as Muslims we
should pack our brother in that day he's
new to 13 and what's the worst thing is
that Muslims going against him come on
what kind of example is that for us we
should sick buyer there and like you
said we're all put in our hands up like
you said the beginning human trafficking
is a sin and disgusting rape sexual
assault webcam I don't like any of these
sexuality it's a sin is disgusting any
culture and the real victims of this
deserve all the sympathy and help they
can get and I really believe that but I
don't believe it
and uh what would be the most harshest
against this you know the strongest
deterrence and the way of life Islam
that comes down the hardest on this and
criminalize it is actually uh God's law
is the Sharia it's you know comes down
the hardest then
um there's a verse in the Quran going
off what you were saying that when an
evil doer comes to you you know verify
it check it up you know and we know that
the media have been the ones not only
lying to you but lying about you you
know how much stuff just uh in general
just speaking about Muslims in general
so just being naive to this fact that
everything now the media tells you uh
what were you going to say yeah you've
seen it with the World Cup in Qatar I
mean if that's no example of media bias
you you think they're going to be uh
neutral with him and uh yeah we don't
some of us was it frustrates me they
don't understand this and see this we
saw in Guantanamo Bay we saw the war in
Iraq we see the war Israel we see the
bias in France media you know yet
again now the media said it like come on
the media portray whatever they want and
a lot of these are tabloids there's no
neutral respect immediate Outlets I mean
the tabloids right people the terms
they're using is so derogatory a real
media outlet should say Andrew Tate has
been caught
um held and arrested detained for the
investigation of this because the other
day he hasn't been convicted of a crime
now again it's frustrating but the
problem is like like you said Sharia law
has an answer to all this the
punishments are worthy to the people who
would do it that's why it's a deterrent
because the fear of the punishments but
yet
the testimonial for witness and the
proof and everything is is the most Fair
system to man and unfortunately who
knows how they even got a warrant
they've obviously got people in the it's
unfortunate and I honestly saw one
non-muslim post a video actually it's a
guy called Tommy Robinson who is
anti-muslim uh a guy we don't agree with
I've seen for years he's a right-wing
Englishman but he made a good point he
said what do you expect when you're out
of business or you pay women to take
their clothes off do you not think you
can pay those same women to go against
you and I was like subhana he's spawn
you know it was like he said this is the
business you're in you were doing that
business before you should have learned
that you're going to pay someone to be
in this kind of sinful world and you pay
them take your clothes off and probably
the same women of course you can pay to
say go against this man because
you'll sell this so unfortunately and
it's just a 30 year old and
I hope inshallah the truth comes out
he's uh released and I hope it also he
takes his big test and tribulation to
learn from as well and it will be I mean
so Allah test Us in the way we learn
from it whether we learn to go away from
God and say why me why me Oh Come Close
and say Allah read the Quran understand
Prophet are you stories of the prophets
who really suffered and went from
hardships and say you know what it's
another trial to see how close I'm to
see my faith and inshallah here he will
so I'm just as a brother like a friend a
long time I just don't want to see him
suffer for something unfortunately like
that
um again like you said clearly if
someone's guilty of that I'm all for it
show me proof I'm all for it but there
won't be it will be witness testimonies
and I don't trust
we've seen a lot of people who are
obviously against some of the things
that he said who've come out and say
look we don't believe this story here's
what you should believe about this story
nothing
so can can we start off by saying that
if you believe that I believe anything
about the story
you don't know me of course I don't
believe it am I going to have fun with
it and pretend as though it's true oh
yes I am of course I am do I believe
it's true very unlikely hugely unlikely
have you seen that you've seen you just
mentioned uh Tommy Robinson also who's
obviously an opponent of Islam and he's
somebody who's testifying on he mentions
a story interesting about uh Mother's
Day that uh you know because a lot of
times our brother Andrew will say
certain things to get a reaction and uh
did you hear this story about uh even
coming from this person talking about
Mother's Day how he do you know about
the story
he mentions how he said you know the
people who are out there wishing happy
Mother's Day you know maybe by getting
our card or Rose you know and he calls
them some derogatory name he goes this
is a real man
he said you know I thought I said mum
how much you own this year 25 000 pounds
there's 10 years wages you don't have to
work again that's what real son does a
son that loves his mum as a son who
cares and he wrote all this stuff and I
used to watch him and I see everyone go
mad
like he knows what he's doing he says
yes his mother he says do you have any
debt or anything he paid off everything
for uh for years he said this is how you
take care of your mother you know this
is coming from you know this is coming
from someone who you wouldn't expect uh
coming from so this is very interesting
when people who are you would say are
your your enemies who are coming say we
don't believe this story
and these are people who who uh who uh
you know you you heard the whole thing
with the pizza box right yeah this is
like crazy another frustrating angle I
mean yeah you know I mean in Romanian
Romania are going to take such
disrespect that you you can fly into a
country everyone knows what you can go
to the most third little poorest country
yet any body or stop with immigration
you'll stop by someone you've got to
show ID papers they knew look at the
camera crew brother look at the camera
crew the pictures the clear HD it was a
Hollywood movie why do they want to
present this what for what reason this
was all Stager plan they could have
are closed up I'm speaking to people
around Andrew and his lawyers and the
last time it happened they could have
called and said come and Andrew would
have willingly gone to police station
ask any answer any questions as
respectful he is you could have easily
invited coming when I speak to you or
private this was a show
all the signs of it it's just something
fishy and I mean and I'm not a
conspiracy there is but sometimes you've
got to say look this is this coincidence
after Piers Morgan after he's reverted
even on the podcast since he revoted
he's a much calmer person he tends to
not get into certain conflicts his
rhetorics calm down a lot people don't
see this they're oh he's this that gift
of another time it's only been a couple
of months Max and uh now this has
happened but
Savannah I uh I'm hoping this is gonna
I mean
a lot of these Circle friends influences
YouTubers upset me as well because many
use him want for the clout want the
likes want the views want to make money
off him yet as a brother now they're
afraid they're afraid to stand up I I
stood up personally privately I mean it
could it could be back five who knows
you never know but I don't care because
I'm thinking someone has to speak up and
say look this is a Muslim brother please
have sub our patience and let's support
him because he's in need now we're a
Brotherhood Islam is I mean we're one
Brotherhood and Sisterhood we're all
together so if you see a brother or need
or a sister who need we help whether
it's zakar charity in war zones this is
a brother and me this is an issue so
what you're gonna do is go against him
that he's a Muslim now or we don't want
to help no I'm gonna stand up and try
and support our brother so
this is the unfortunate thing we have
yes yes this is
Jack from Modern potato
you guys from the same place yeah yeah
alhamdulillah they came to the dial
table today my brother Andrew take fan
something like that tell us something
about today
your thoughts your reaction my brother
to this young brother except in Islam
yeah beautiful this I I actually uh
shared this story on social media
it was beautiful and uh it's kind of
emotional to watch because this innocent
kids and brother you should I've gone in
books full unfortunately sometimes it uh
I don't really see a lot of it but
sometimes I reply many people said to me
I used to hate Islam before since I've
seen Andrew I've got into it um what do
I do to revert brother many you'll be
shocked and of course I like to post it
or share it because I want their privacy
and I want them to feel you know
uh it's a special thing but subhanallah
like they log in he promoted Islam for
the last five years let's go how many
years he's been on socials
promoting the
benefits to Islam before Islam and now
he does it as a Muslim yet we're still
against his brother I mean come on
his platform's huge to reach the world
so again I I don't understand why the
Muslims are not totally backing him
here's what I say remember the Tim
as long as our brother Andrew he keeps
learning and growing in Islam and
establishing his connection with his
creator in Salah he'll continue to
evolve to be a better Muslim which means
a better all-around human being and a
real top Muslim not a top G forget about
this Dunya stuff but a top servant to
the one Creator God Almighty Allah and
brothers and sisters let's give our
brother the benefit of the doubt let's
make Dua for him that he comes out even
more committed to the Deen and that
Allah makes it easy for him to leave off
any Haram dealings
from the past this could be difficult
this is the Jihad this is a struggle and
that Allah the almighty uses him to
spread this Deen this way of life and
puts the love of dawah in his heart and
inshallah hopefully the truth comes out
and inshallah I look forward to seeing
brother Andrew and your show as soon as
he's out inshallah then uh we can relax
yes inshallah my brother it was nice
having you on again inshallah will
connect soon in the future cannot leave
without giving you a gift if you are not
yet Muslim and you tune in to see what
these Muslims are talking about and you
like a free copy of the Quran go and
visit thedenshow.com we'll take care of
the postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you